[Music]
weird story recently a state legislature
introduced a bill that would make it
illegal
illegal in this country to photoshop
someone's head
onto a naked body without their
permission
yeah
in other words this means that if this
law catches on it could very soon be
illegal for us to photoshop celebrities
heads onto naked bodies and it's so much
fun
so
the idea is this window may be closing
fast
so i must act quickly
for no reason at all here's kim jong-un
right now
yeah
here
here's ron paul ron paul's there he's uh
he's good yeah he's
he's good shape
he's held up well the hat is real that's
real
uh yeah uh simon cowell got to show you
simon cowell
nancy pelosi got a uh nancy pelosi's
here
she's the only one who's not going to
sue us
winston churchill you got to get winston
churchill in there if you can
explain who he is later newt gingrich
newt gingrich of course
and finally john madden uh
[Music]
all right just trying to get in under
the wire